these are the children of the islamic
state
all of them brought up in the caliphate
and terrorized by the militants
their parents are fighters or is
supporters
but now they've the chance of a new life
in this 24-hour guarded facility in
northern syria
they're being taught about the outside
world and a whole set of different
values
some of them are foreigners this little
boy is a french citizen
he was just nine when he was taken over
to join the caliphate four years ago
all of them here are between 10 and 18
years old
still minors
this is what they've left behind the
so-called cubs of the caliphate were put
through
rigorous physical training and proudly
exploited on is propaganda videos
they were expected to kill and used as
an example of the extreme loyalty
the terror group demanded
thirteen-year-old pierre
not his real name was taken to raqqa by
his father with his two elder brothers
all three are dead now but his mother's
alive and in paris
and he's desperate to go back
he's hand made gifts which he hopes
we'll be able to deliver to his mother
in paris
and he's written a letter to her telling
how much he loves
and misses her and his life in france
the boys are all understandably subdued
they've endured a lot
the conditions of our meetings include
not asking details of what they did for
is
but they frequently mention their
traumatic experiences
[Music]
when i was in the isis region i used to
see lots of people whose arms and legs
had been amputated by is
and there was a lot of blood so when i
first came here i had lots of really bad
nightmares
but now i'm slowly getting over it
a lot of the boys were taken to syria by
their parents
13 14 16 after years in the war zone
this young man wants to be an english
teacher
there are cameras everywhere to protect
the boys from each other as well as from
themselves
their past makes them prone to violent
outbursts and many are now utterly alone
in the world
this french boy from toulouse seen here
on the left saw his two brothers killed
in a bomb attack
his mother's a fighter still with is
he's got no one left
and no idea what the future holds
most of these boys were fighting against
the coalition some were surrounded and
gave themselves up
some were even found with suicide vests
or were captured fighting
a few had parents with senior positions
in the caliphate
it's going to take a while to reverse
years of living with is
and even then an uncertain future awaits
with most of the european governments
shunning the cubs of the caliphate who
came from their countries
alex crawford sky news in northern syria